the US and Cuba's icy relationship
continues to defrost this week with two
countries reopened embassies in Havana
and Washington after 54 years it's
another victory for the Obama
administration's diplomacy kick and part
of the White House is pushed to
normalize relations with Cuba which
included dropping the country from a
list of states that sponsor terrorism
what's next for the two countries as
they rebuild a relationship first
there's trust even though in April Obama
said on Cuba we are not in the business
of regime change Raul Castro and Cuban
officials are still unconvinced that the
US will leave the communist government
be remember ever since the 1959
revolution the US has wanted the Castro
brothers out and it's tried to make it
happen either by force as in the Bay of
Pigs or one of the many CIA plots to
kill Fidel Castro or more recently by
supporting government opposition via
programs of USAID by the same token
critics of the deal say Cuba needs to do
more to address human rights issues and
democracy before there can be trust will
there be a McDonald's and Starbucks on
every Havana street corner not likely
though Airbnb and Netflix have launched
on the island and Google and Twitter are
chomping at the bit even if the Castro's
embrace multinationals with open arms
which is a big if foreign investment and
trade will take some time first there is
a world of Cuban bureaucracy legal
systems and tax structures designed for
well a state controlled economy but the
bigger hurdle is a US trade embargo in
place since 1962
it doesn't just restrict American
business in Cuba but imports like
medical supplies which has had grave
consequences for Cubans health and if
Obama wants to drop the embargo he needs
Congress's approval to do it but given
the Republicans control both houses
it'll be a near impossible sell wrapped
up in the embargoes legality our travel
restrictions for Americans trying to get
to the island lifting those restrictions
also depends on Congress but more and
more Americans are taking their chances
American travel to Cuba is up 36% and
airlines are trying to capitalize on it
JetBlue just started daily flights to
Havana
finally there's Guantanamo Raul Castro
is said that in order for relations with
the u.s. to truly normalize Cuba needs
control over the bay and the base
American officials say it's not up for
discussion a lot of it comes down to the
detention facility which still remains
open with a hundred and sixteen
prisoners despite its closure being one
of Obama's first presidential promises
so how far will Cuba and the u.s. get in
figuring all of this out and could
political changes in either country
rollback these diplomatic games